i was sitting there and it was like the
lord spoke to me and said cut it off
you're listening to the devil talk to
you right now
and it was it was you could feel
something inside it was almost like
inside your head
trying to to to rearrange the rubik's
cube it's like i'm there and it's like
my thoughts were like i'm like wait a
minute that's uh get it back on the
bible but you could feel
a spirit trying to change the way that
you were thinking by listening the bible
says that there's coming a last grand
deception how can we make sure that
we're part of the elect find out on this
episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness welcome
everybody to led live today we got an
exciting topic about the deception of
the last days i'm always excited to talk
about prophecy and last days deceptions
and how we can
you know things that we can do to not be
deceived so we got our guests with us
eric wilson he's been on the show a
number of times you have a wealth of
knowledge i always like doing shows with
you man you bring out some good points
so what do you got for us about this
last great deception and what is this
cosmic christ we're talking about well
what we're going to be looking at today
is based on a prophecy that we find in
the gospels jesus said that there were
going to be
many people that would come in the last
days claiming to be him claiming to be
christ and actually before we go
um i was going to ask keith if he would
open up and read one of those prophecies
for us from our savior okay so this is
from mark 13 14 14-22 if you want to
follow along it says so when you see the
abomination of desolation spoken of by
daniel the prophet standing where it
ought not
then let those who are in judea flee to
the mountains let him who is on the
housetop not go down into the house nor
enter to take anything out of his house
and let him who is in the field not go
back to get his clothes
but woe to those who are pregnant and to
those who are nursing babies in those
days
and pray that your flight may not be in
the winter
for in those days there will be a
tribulation such as not been since the
beginning of the creation of god which
created until this time nor ever shall
be and unless the lord had shortened
those days no flesh would be saved but
for the elect's sake whom he choose he
shortened those days if anyone says to
you look here is the christ or look he
is there do not believe it for false
christs and false prophets will rise and
show signs and wonders to deceive if
possible even the elect
and take heed or says but take heed see
i have told you all things beforehand
amen that first part reminds me of like
you know the basic instructions when
there's a fire just get out don't run
back in for anything even though it
might be impulse just leave amen amen
one thing i notice in here is he's
saying you know
if there's anyone who says they're
christ in some secret place or in the
desert don't look that that is a clue to
me that if anyone is on earth saying i'm
christ it can't be him right because
that's right that's why it's so
important for us to understand certain
things in prophecy how it's going to
play out you know a lot of people say
well we can agree to disagree on certain
things but i think all of it you know i
think all these little little false
doctrines or little misunderstandings
will trip you up in the big scheme of
everything do you know something that um
that you just said that really has also
it stood in my mind
if they say he's there don't go look
and we're going to see here
this is happening right now i wish we
had some of the video footage but there
are there are men all over the world
right now claiming to be jesus christ
you've got a man down in uh in miami
that's got millions of followers you've
got a guy in russia that's been claiming
to be christ he used to be a police
officer he's got thousands of followers
you've got another man somewhere down in
south america that has got a mansion
down there millions of followers you
think they'd follow the script you know
be a carpenter or a lowly yeah but if
when you read through the prophecies all
throughout the bible christ doesn't
touch earth for the second that's right
so that's a telltale sign that no i
don't think he's over there or living in
a mansion that's right compete with what
the bible is saying
what really struck me is is that jesus
says when they say that i'm over there
don't even look and we're going to see
this coming up
when the antichrist
the main one the main one who is
claiming to be christ appears the whole
world is going to see them on the
internet on their cell phones i mean
right now people live in grass huts with
a dirt floor in some countries and
they've got a cell phone or they've got
they've got access
so christ is like don't even look
because if it were possible this will
deceive even the very last very
convincing so convincing he's saying
don't even look because yeah because you
would be you could be deceived and i've
realized that because i'm thinking okay
adam and eve were
pure and holy and had never sinned
and eve was deceived adam was not
deceived because
he knew better
he chose to do it but eve was deceived
by this being
that they had been warned about oh you
make a good point because sometimes the
deception isn't only in not knowing it's
the pressure to go ahead and go with it
so we may see the deception for what it
is but be like adam and say oh but my
family and uh a job or whatever and
that's right that's a good point wow
yeah that's a good point another thing i
see also in that in the
verse that we're just reading uh
is
when people talking to you the deception
to hear it's like
it sounds very like jesus yes you know
what i said and they could how's gonna
be the difference you know yes and like
it would take more time just to listen
or just go to those places they say
don't even go look at it yeah because if
you look i mean
we've never seen an angel show up in in
brilliance what would you do i mean
think about the people now that are
having experiences and they go i know it
was of god because the way i felt
what are you going to do when lucifer i
don't even call him lucifer satan
himself appears
as a dazzling being and people are going
to go that was christ he healed the sick
he was raising the dead he
what are people going to do so i was
thinking about there's so much
propaganda with this caricature of the
devil being with horns and he's red with
a pitchfork
that people they they associate oh no he
looks scary so if if i feel love or i
see you know light then that can't be
the devil because he can't make you feel
love right well ecstasy can make you
feel love right you can pop a drug so we
can't we can't fall for that we i think
that's the biggest trick is that he's
trying to make no satan's really scary
looking and that makes you feel bad and
evil we got to stand on this thus saith
the lord
when christ comes there's no controversy
in who he is amen the bible says every
knee will bow every
and so you're not going to have
differing opinions even though these men
don't want to admit it will admit it the
devil himself will bow
amen
good point let's jump into another verse
uh this is in second thessalonians
chapter two it says the apostle paul was
inspired he wrote to us and said let no
man deceive you by any means
for that day speaking of the day of
christ's return
shall not come except there come a
falling away first and the word falling
away doesn't mean
abandoning christ it means an apostasy
every time the nation of israel
old testament israel went into apostasy
they didn't say okay we're not going to
serve god
most often it was we're going to blend
god with paganism
normally that's what the apostasy looked
like
and here we're told that there's going
to be an apostasy
and that man of sin will be revealed the
word revealed in greek actually means
unmasked or unveiled
so that tells us it tells me when i read
that
satan is going to veil his glory
and then it's going to be unveiled
he's going to be seen for who he really
is
and it calls him something that says the
son of perdition
that phrase is only used two times in
all of scripture
this verse and one verse in the gospels
about judas right about judas
and what and this really struck me
because
i wasn't digging for it it was like the
lord just opened my eyes one day and i
was like son of perdition sign of
perdition wait a minute that's what
jesus said about judas
when jesus was first gathering the
disciples to him
judas came among them
jesus didn't call judas judas wanted a
place because he he saw this man he saw
the following that was happening and he
thought
he could be the christ he could be the
king that we've all been waiting for and
if i get in now
i'm getting in on the ground floor you
know i'll have a place a high place in
that kingdom when judas came among them
jesus said have i not chosen you 12 and
yet one of you
has a devil has an evil spirit from the
day that jesus had begun there was an
evil spirit that was working in judas's
life and jesus knew it
um we're told i believe it's in desire
of ages that that spirit was a spirit
called selfishness
it wasn't like he was cutting himself or
throwing up or had you know grotesque
things he was doing
it was just selfishness had taken the
throne of his heart
okay so he's got an evil spirit that's
influenced him and he's in ministry
for three and a half years with our
savior
on the last night
before they came to take christ and
arrest him he's at the passover supper
and you can read this in in each of the
gospels
and um i believe it was peter
john was sitting right next to jesus it
says he had his head like laying on
jesus's chest and he was younger he was
the youngest of the disciples which that
really appeals to me because it's like
maybe he was 17 or something the other
guys are in their 20s or 30s you know
and jesus was young he was only you know
33 by that time
but john is like leaning on him maybe
it's late at night and
peter's like john
ask him
who this person is who the one is that's
going to deceive him because jesus said
told them one of you is going to deceive
it or portray me
and peter said ask him who it is
and jesus said the one that dips his
bread when i dip my bread
that's who it is and about that time
jesus took his bread and he dipped it
in whatever the the oil or whatever they
were dipping it in
and
judas reached and dipped at the exact
same time and jesus looked at him and he
said what thou doest do quickly
and this is what caught me
it says at that moment satan himself
entered into judas
so there was an evil spirit that had
kept the door open
selfishness one sin had kept that door
open and because judas had continually
yielded to that
satan said i'm not going to leave this
job to any other evil spirit i'm taking
this job no one's going to mess up on
this because they're they're angels but
they do mess up and they get in trouble
when they mess up with satan he was like
i'm taking this job i'm going to be the
one that makes sure he gets put on the
cross
and jesus called him the son of
perdition
satan entered into a man
so without giving the whole story away
that's that's something just to kind of
pay attention to look how subtle the
contract signing was
you know dipping something seemingly
insignificant dipping your bread in some
oil it wasn't like you know drawing
blood or something like that
it's something that
someone could overlook yeah that's
that's exactly so miraculous signs and
wonders we might be looking for one
particular thing and neglecting these
small what we perceive as small that are
actually pretty miraculous in context to
what's going on or a kiss on the cheek
to your savior you know that's a good
point too one thing i'm noticing about
this unmasked unveiled we see a lot of
movies about the end times you know it's
always like
this ruler who just hates christians you
know i think that's the false perception
you know it's like that would be way too
obvious so i remember like obama was in
the office and stuff and they were like
look he's blaspheming he hates the bible
and all this i'm like
that that's not very deceiving isn't it
more deceptive is someone who's gonna
have to be unveiled on mass because you
don't see it on the surface right yeah
that's what i think we're seeing here
that's why it has to be unmasked
the apostle paul goes on and says
speaking of this son of perdition the
man of sin it says who opposeth and
exalteth himself above all that is
called god
or that is worshipped so that he as god
sitteth in the temple of god showing
himself that he is god
and then he says and this this really
was startling he said remember ye not
that when i was yet with you i told you
these things and i was like wait a
minute this is second thessalonians and
he's saying last time i was with you
i told you about this
if you go back to first thessalonians
there's some there's some clues about
what he's talking about here he says
remember you not that when i was yet
with you i told you these things
but now you know
he that is withholding he that's holding
back this last deception he says you
know him because you know god and you
know christ
he says that he might be revealed in
this time so god is holding this
deception back so that it can be
revealed unveiled in the perfect time
and then the apostle paul says for the
mystery of iniquity doth already work
and on this picture that we've got on
the screen this really struck me because
this is an old greek or roman
theater and it was funny because when
you go into the bible and you look up
the word hypocrites where jesus says you
know you hypocrites talking to the
pharisees the greek word is actors and
actresses
in the greek theater in the roman
theater
there was something behind a mask
and paul just got finished saying this
thing is going to be unveiled it's going
to be unmasked
he says the mystery of iniquity doth
already work
so for me i love mysteries i love
figuring out riddles and secrets i think
all of us do and even as bible students
it's like there's nothing more than oh
god what is this you know help me to
understand this and you know i found
something that nobody else has seen
and it's like i was like lord what is
this mystery of iniquity and i started
searching all these other you know
authors and writers and theologians and
a lot of people have really dug into
that for years what is this mystery of
iniquity
and then the lord showed me something
that was just really startling there's
actually two mysteries that are talked
about in the bible
you have the mystery of iniquity in
second thessalonians and then you have
another mystery that's called the
mystery of godliness
and the lord just impressed me one day
eric it's a counterfeit right
if you want to know what is wrong with
the counterfeit how to identify it
understand what the truth is if you want
to know what the mystery of iniquity is
find out what the mystery of godliness
is so we'll get there in just a second
because that really it opens up a lot
this is a quote from a little book
called testimonies to ministers and this
this was really startling it says as we
near the close of time there will be a
greater and still greater external
parade of heathen power
and i thought okay that means there's
going to be a lot of heathen people
doing heathen things but then it goes on
it says
heathen deities will manifest their
signal power and will exhibit themselves
before the cities of the world
and i was like
oh wow i mean like you know there's a
part of me that's like oh wow this is
going to be cool and oh wow this is
going to be a little bit scary but i
thought heathen deities are going to
exhibit themselves before the cities of
the world and i thought one day
and then the lord said keep reading the
very next sentence says and this
delineation has already begun to be
fulfilled
and you know what i was thinking is
heathen deities have exhibited
themselves before the cities of the
world
now i understand do you watch some of
the videos that you guys have done and
that we've done superheroes and stuff
you've got
hollywood actors you've got musicians
you've got authors that are all claiming
there's evil spirits that come into me
to so that i can act and perform that
wasn't me on stage
that's interesting wording heathen
deities will manifest their signal i
mean there's a there's a
large acceptance of eastern religion and
people are saying i will man let me
manifest such a good
so yes of course on a large scale
actors and whatnot what about
you know regular people which actors
just like the general population who is
manifest or wanting to manifest and
these heathen deities are doing it
through them and you know some of the
eastern like the the hindu and some of
the buddhists and stuff they will
actually say that our purpose here is to
manifest our innate divinity they're
saying that we're gods which that's
exactly what satan told eve in the
garden of eden
you will be like god and they're saying
well that's our whole goal is to
manifest that we are gods
and then the author of this book says
all need wisdom carefully to search out
the mystery of iniquity
heathen deities are going to manifest
before the cities of the world
and they equate this with the mystery of
iniquity that figures so largely in the
winding up of earth's history so for me
i was like okay mystery of iniquity and
we've got mystery of godliness
so we look at the mystery of godliness
first timothy 3 16 it tells us somebody
says i want to be a godly man i want to
be a godly woman this is the only way it
can happen
it says and without controversy
great is the mystery of godliness
god was manifest in the flesh wow
there's no other way that we can be
godly except god is manifest in our
flesh christ is manifest in us the hope
of glory he's asking for the same thing
no go
expand
so i mean okay so let's go back to the
verse what was it oh second
thessalonians first thessalonians 3
first timothy 3 16. first timothy 3 16.
so god was manifest in the flesh yes
oh he's talking about jesus though not
not us
let me let me show you something look at
this one you will love this candy second
corinthians chapter four he says always
bearing about speaking of us always
bearing about in our body the dying of
the lord jesus
so that the life also of jesus might be
made manifest in our body wow
and it gets better listen to the next
one for we which live are always
delivered unto death for jesus's sake so
that the life also of jesus might be
made manifest in our mortal flesh
you know satan isn't that creative is he
he's taken
exactly what's in the bible and twisting
it but yeah it just goes back to the
constant war who is on the throne of
your heart who has your attention who
who are you allowing to manifest and all
these things in our lives it's
that's incredible amen
and for me this i got excited because i
was like
by understanding this is what the devil
is going to do manifest in human flesh i
was like
but that's what god wants to do that's
what the bible and all of a sudden
christ in you the hope of glory is like
that's not just a theological
phrase
he wants to live in us
like if you get a chance to read that
book desire of ages page 161 that was
god's purpose from the very beginning is
for him to live and dwell inside of us
literally
and that's exciting i'm like we've got a
god that loves us so much he wants to be
one with us
there's a similar
thought expressed in colossians chapter
it says i now rejoice this is verse 24
in my sufferings for you and fill up in
my flesh
what is lacking in the afflictions of
christ for the sake of his body which is
the church in which i became a minister
according to the stewardship from god
which was given to me for you to fulfill
the word of god the mystery which has
been hidden from ages and from
generations but is now revealed to his
saints
to them god willed to make known were
the riches of his glory of this mystery
among the gentiles
which is christ in you the hope of glory
wow
look at that it says the mystery which
has been hid from ages and from
generations but has now made manifest to
us
god
in us let me i'm going to give you one
more i know we're taking stuff that we
don't have on the screen but forgive me
bible study man yeah turn turn there if
you have a bible with you this is so
beautiful um it's second corinthians
chapter six
and people i've had people tell me
before well you're taking that too
literally i'm like listen when i read
the gospels jesus raised the dead he
healed the sick he cast out demons it
was literal
i want a god that will manifest himself
in my life literally i don't need just
head knowledge the power of sin over sin
amen i don't think any promise god says
to us is figurative amen the promise is
a promise he plans to do it candy if you
would um read this at second corinthians
actually read verse 14 is chapter 6
verse 14 through 16. stop forming
inappropriate relationships with
unbelievers
can right and wrong be partners can
light have anything in common with
darkness amen can christ agree with the
devil interesting
can a believer share life with an
unbeliever can god's temple contain
false gods clearly we are the temple of
the living god
as god said
i will live and walk among them i will
be their god and they will be my people
amen
in the king james it says you are the
temple of the living god as god has said
i will dwell in them and i will walk in
them if it was literal in christ's life
and he said he was he said the words i'm
speaking it's not me speaking it it's my
father that's in me the miracles i'm
doing it's god in me i and my father are
one
in john chapter 17 21 that was his last
prayer before calvary he said father i
want them all to be one like you and i
are one
god was in christ reconciling the world
that's what he wants to do in us
wow
also i want to share uh ephesians
chapter 3 verse 16.
ephesians 3 16 yes okay
you know we're talking about the you
know god in us and stuff like that yes
sir uh it says that that he will grant
you according to the riches of his glory
to be in strengthened with the might by
his spirit and the inner man
wow
to be strengthened
with might
keith do you have a
strong's on your computer
look and see what that word might is
i wonder i know sometimes it'll be like
dunamis but i don't know if that's what
that is in that verse in ephesians 3
which is like dynamic miracles so it's
by his spirit we can we're gonna be you
know a strength
with his might and his spirit
inciting us so it's not a little wicky
crazy you know christian out there you
know that because a lot of people in the
world say oh yeah you guys christian you
guys cannot do what you know i'm saying
like no we have that's what it is what
tell us what's the word yeah that's what
it is dunamis
and what's the definition
while he looks for that in my
translation in verse 17 when we continue
from what you were reading
then christ shall live in you through
faith and what that tells me is
if if there's faith involved that means
there's not necessarily always some
outward some massive expression that
christ is living inside of us not saying
it doesn't happen miracles happens all
the time um just the fact that we're
breathing is a miracle but
sometimes it's just a regular day
but christ is still living within us so
it's basically you know
depending on
how it's used it could be strength it
could be power or it could be might
those are kind of the
words involved depending on the passage
there's a there's another definition too
uh miraculous power for dunamos it's
yeah you know it's interesting like you
said candy too christ lived here for 30
years
prior to us seeing him enter his
ministry right and he lived and god was
in him that's right
amen
before we move on i just wanted to bring
out the dual application here
where it says god was manifest in flesh
and candy was saying oh that's jesus
yeah so you got
god manifesting in the flesh as jesus
and then you also have god manifesting
in the flesh and his people and we're
the body of we're the body of christ
yeah and so the counterfeit is not only
satan manifesting in the flesh as the
antichrist but also satan manifesting in
all the people amen who are doing his
will through all of his evil spirits
that are getting in through all his you
know millions of ways so you're
literally you're a follower of christ
you're a follower satan you're under one
of the two flags that's right
i'm going to go on just a little bit
more from that book testimonies to
ministers it says the perils of the last
days are upon us
and in our work we are to warn the
people of the danger that they are in
let not the solemn scenes which prophecy
has been has revealed be left untouched
if our people as christians were half
awake if they realized the nearness of
the events portrayed in the book of
revelation
a reformation would be wrought in our
churches and many more would believe the
message
we have no time to lose god calls upon
us to watch for souls as those that must
give an account and that was written in
the 1800s if the church was half a week
do you guys feel like you're in danger
i feel like the whole world's in danger
yeah
because based off of what
this this author is saying in the
beginning
like we are to warn people of the danger
that they are in
just like so that can be difficult
sometimes when they can't see it even in
scripture the lord will come and people
will be marrying and partying and this
would be like just like it's the same
old thing
yeah
do you know what's neat though cause
like sometimes i've i've had people tell
me um warning people the danger means
you're doing that wrong and you know and
you get resistance
if somebody can see and i'm not saying
that we're not supposed to preach but
i'm saying
if you're living a life of holiness and
victory
other people they want that
i remember i heard a man one time he was
talking about look if you're if you're
trying to witness to a muslim here we've
got a whole series of studies of how to
witness to a muslim if you're trying to
witness to a buddhist here's a whole
series of studies on how to witness to a
buddhist and in my mind i'm thinking
it's techniques it's like sales pitch
how do i how do i wiggle my way in and
squirm my way in between their guard
and then it was like the lord was like
eric it's easy
whether you're a buddhist or a hindu or
a muslim or a christian
you've all got the same problems you've
all got problems in your marriages
you've got problems with children you've
got problems at work you've got problems
i don't care who you are you know when
you feel guilty when you've done wrong
you can say i don't believe in god how
can you still feel guilty
you feel guilt for sin because god put
that inside of us
but we have the answer so instead of
trying to do theological wiggle you know
through and play a chess game and get
through their defenses
address where they're hurting
show them i've got an answer that can
fix that you've got a disease guess what
i know exactly the the herb that will
help to fix that and you know what then
they'll want to know everything that
they can find out about the christ and
the god you serve yeah and that makes it
easy because it says the love of god or
the love of christ is what brings a
person to repentance not because you're
saying you're doing wrong they already
know they're doing wrong that's right
they don't want to hear it or whatever
but when they see that love that
compassion coming through hey i got i
can help you
why are you so loving you know yeah it's
like mary magdalene i mean she was a
prostitute she didn't need jesus to yell
at her and say you're a prostitute
you're gonna go to hell you better
change and you're like
but he looked at her and he said
she saw that he loved her because she
was probably unclothed
to the most part
i'm sure he draped something over her
he was hiding her shame where everybody
else was trying to expose her
and so him just covering her
was showing his love
when everybody else is like they got the
stones ready and jesus is like
you know i'm not condemning you i'm not
saying that what you're doing is right
that i didn't come here to punish you i
came here to set you free and that's
what we've got to do as christians
i'd like to give an example to your
point about warnings because there are
different kinds of warnings and we need
to act appropriately depending on the
circumstance yes there's the warning
that a mother is yelling or not even
yelling just run and grabs her child if
they're in the street and a car is
coming but i remember there's another
kind of warning i was at a church social
running playing have a good having a
good time with my friends
but the
church the basement that we were in had
these pillars my mom just kept saying
hey you know calm down stop running
around well she wasn't screaming at me
she was just telling me calmly stop
running around but i kept doing it i was
having fun
anyway i ran and just smacked right into
the pill i actually still have the bump
today
um if i just listen to that warning you
know that didn't look like there was any
danger um but based off of what we were
doing we were heading into danger
so that's just you know an example of
different types of warning that are
still as important yes and will prevent
us from
some painful consequences all kinds of
warnings in our world and a lot of them
are silent witnesses
you know
you can pick up all kinds of products
and there is a
you know
something on there that says warning i
mean there's certain chemicals i
remember when i worked in a laboratory
it's the only time i was really
uh unsettled with the stuff i was
working with i pulled out a bottle as
from the bayer chemical company it was
this big
very little tiny bottle we just used it
to make a standard
and on that bottle was a skull and
crossbones
oh wow
and i was like
better make sure i have those gloves on
you know better make sure you have your
your eyewear protection on better make
sure you have which we did anyway
but
the label wasn't screaming at me
it wasn't talking to me at all but it
was saying something
you know
and so
that's that's a you know for those
people who drink coffee or hot beverages
or something there's a warning on there
this is hot it's not screaming at you
you can choose to slam it if you want
but you're going to suffer the
consequences there's all kinds of
warnings that are silent warnings that
we encounter from day to day amen
good point
the apostle paul in 1st thessalonians we
go back you know one one book in the
bible first thessalonians chapter 5
verse 1 and 2.
he kind of gives us a hint of what he
was talking about in 2 thessalonians he
says
but of the times and seasons brethren
you have no need that i write unto you
for you yourselves know perfectly that
the day of the lord so cometh as a thief
in the night i have a lot of christians
tell me that well don't we don't need to
know prophecy because it's coming like a
thief in the night and they quote that
one verse
but if you read the name if you read the
next statement he says
for when they shall say peace and safety
then sudden destruction shall come upon
them as travail upon a woman with child
and they shall not escape you know
whenever i hear peace and safety you
know i'm not being conspiracy but i
think of the u.n because that's what
they're all about peace and safety
um
you know we've got this picture here on
the screen of the whole world being
brought together you know let's all just
get along put aside our differences and
unite the apostle paul goes on and says
the lord's coming like a thief in the
night but then listen to what the next
statement is
but you brethren are not in darkness
that that day should overtake you as a
thief
you are all the children of light and
children of the day
god says
his word is a lamp into our feet and a
light under our path so if we're
children of the light it's because this
is what we feed on
if you eat light you'll be filled with
light if you eat darkness you'll be
filled with darkness he says
we are all children of light and
children of the day we are not of the
night nor of darkness therefore let us
not sleep as do others but let us watch
and be sober
i can remember when i was a young man
was not living for god at all i used to
drink lots of alcohol every i drank
every day i mean every day
on the job off the job because i worked
for myself you know we worked in an auto
shop where we did security systems and i
mean we just drank all the time
i was never sober
god is telling us be sober
that doesn't mean simply don't drink it
means
keep your mind focused on what matters
focus on the on the time that we're
living in if i knew that was that christ
was coming this friday
would i be at a football game on
wednesday i mean could i go and sit and
watch
the super bowl knowing that in two days
the end of the world was going to happen
there's no i mean i'd be sitting there
going
who cares who wins the football game
christ is coming
and christ is telling us that people
will say well why are you always picking
on movies or why are you always picking
on this and i'm like if you realize the
time that we're living in would i have
time to waste on things that are less
important
i mean how many people on the road where
i live don't know jesus
don't know he's coming back don't know
that he really loves them
so i'm going to sit and goof off for
hours reading a book or playing a game a
video game when there's people down the
road that are going to burn because they
don't know
and that doesn't mean go down and beat
their door down yelling at them but
at least get to know him yeah i don't
even i mean i i'm guilty i don't really
know my neighbors that well i've met
them but it's not like we hang out or
anything and
it's like you take them a gift you buy
them a loaf of bread or you take them
flowers or you just say hey i just you
just befriend people
and that opens the door for conversation
yeah good a good way to start that too
is um
asking them
what you can pray about for them yeah
that's a good thing yeah because then
you have this follow-up built in you you
need to come back and see has the lord
been answering amen that prayer amen and
and people are generally open to prayer
whether that
you know whatever life has brought them
you know it's you're right keith because
it's like if you show concern hey i'd
like to pray for you is there anything
that you could use prayer for
even most atheists will not get in an
argument or get you know you know a ball
of knots over that they're like yeah you
know my aunt's got cancer you know would
you pray for that if you pray
in in faith god will answer and then all
of a sudden that person's like man i
remember that guy that woman prayed for
me or prayed for my aunt that's how we
tear those walls down
so paul is telling us that
a deceiver is coming
someone who is is looks one way but
there's really something else hiding
behind the mask
and there's a number of different
cultures that have talked about this you
know the mayans talked about it
the aztecs talked about i think it was a
quetzalcoatl was the name of the god
that they have been expecting to come
how do you pronounce it quetzalcoatl
but they prophesied that this being
quits a cuddle or what's a cut gets that
quote
we'll just dub his voice right that's
right i'll do that um yeah
but in the prophecies like the mayan
prophecies it's this is scary they
actually said that when and you bear
with me quetzalcoatl now i'm not even
going to be able to say it correctly
or messed up
they said that when he returned he was
coming with 12 lesser gods with him and
i thought 12. that's in the mayan
prophecies 12 disciples yeah 12
disciples i mean that's just why would
it why would the pagan have that
didn't they have a base 12 number system
i don't know
that's why they're 12 months they did
really i think they had a base 12 number
system
let me check that do you know that would
be interesting too because if you had
the sun god which is sort of symbolic of
the son of god
and you had 12 signs of the zodiac
which would be the 12
lesser gods the 12 planetary gods no no
these base 20. so it must have been
another
another culture civilization another
culture yeah another civilization and it
could be the incas or one of those
base 12.
so but it's not the mayans
jumping in from there you know we've got
a picture on the screen of what's called
a ziggurat or a pyramid the the ziggurat
is a stepped pyramid not a perfect one
um
you know the incas used this the mayans
the aztecs they found them all in every
culture around the world they have found
ziggurats
and that tells me something wherever
these people
had been scattered from they brought
with them the memory of one
pyramid
or a ziggurat
tower of babel
the whole world was gathered together as
one at the tower of babel and god said
this is not going to go good
not that he was scared of them but he
said if we don't stop this now there's
nothing that they won't accomplish that
they're putting their minds to have you
been to one of those places no
i've been have you it is such an amazing
we went to these ruins uh in 2011
and
i don't know
it was not holiday or anything they're
kind of small no like uh i'm from
chiapas this border
of mexico and guatemala and it's one of
the very
nice uh the mayans ruins is palenque
uh it's in the middle of the jungle like
seriously like you see it's a square the
jungle and the middle is the city
they didn't have airplanes right i mean
it's another topic right we can go
through the but it's interesting it's
like in the middle of the of the jungle
is the huge city and they call it the
the white
uh city why because those
that's the only ones the stones the
stones are so white
wow natural naturally it's not like
browns laid out or something like that
you know through the years you know it's
kind of old or something better you
clean it i mean it's white beautiful
and then it's another city it's called
buena pak
and
uh when we went it's kind of like the
small ones
of that area right
and nobody was there i'm not kidding you
like me and my wife i mean we're like do
you want to go to the tour i was like
yeah you know what is here but the thing
is it's so quiet yeah can you hear the
wind i mean
i mean not getting here so we were
walking around and you know reading and
everything but the one thing i would
just want to tell you is that
you walk there and just to click in your
head is like
can you imagine just 100 years ago
there were people here you know like the
whole civilization they were they were
using so my point is
and i i asked the guy i was like
where were is there more digging here
and stuff like that you say yeah do you
see all these a little a little hill the
little teeny hills you know close to
them
is it
underground it's more pyramids wow i was
like why yeah
the thing is there for the you know the
budget and the government all stuff
that's why a lot of people from
uh another countries they come over here
they get permit and it's like hey you
wanna you know spend the money you know
your budget go do it but they uh the one
thing
they were so
just
they were very sacrificial and yeah
stories and all stuff that just in the
50s they just learned they found this
king
and
that was the uh the son of the god
yeah interesting right yeah song of the
god and they just found in the 50s the
tomb
and it's just a lot of history you know
that is amazing do you notice another
prophecy
uh that gets a quote
uh
they were waiting uh because they when
they came the cri the
the the spaniards that came from europe
to mexico about no mexico but that was
the the land right here in america
and
they found the cross
and they thought it was like oh there
was christ in here you know christian
they already came to
to evangelize
and they said no that's north south east
west
and the thing is they and they said well
all the stuff that you guys learn about
to do good and to do evil that's wrong
and everything because every
civilization has like
like rules you know like laws and
everything what do you guys do learn
that
one a prophet
came
wise it was not white skin but it was
like light lighter than lighter than
they were yeah with the beer and let me
tell you
indigenous
you know mexicans you know aztecs and
mayans you don't see any beer over there
you don't say and they say that they
this person can't even teach us how to
do the good and all the stuff amen we
say but never saw that person again and
that's prophetic and they're
and and the aztecs and mayans uh
prophecy amen so interesting that is
very interesting yeah now we're going to
talk about another one and we're going
to we're going to mention a couple of
these but this is one of the primary uh
figures that are being promoted right
now
it is the uh
it's called the buddha or matreya buddha
the buddha of loving kindness this
matreya it's actually called the matreya
project if you look it up online
they started i believe it was in 1990 91
somewhere right around there they
started gathering money and they are
planning and preparing to erect the
world's largest buddha statue 500 foot
interesting 500-foot statue
in india of the matreya buddha and you
go okay well who cares i mean i've had
people tell me before at church i've
never even heard of betrayal what how is
this important let me show you why this
is a man named benjamin krem
he has spoken at the united nations he
has spoken at
huge gatherings with world leaders they
invite him to come and speak
because he channels
the spirit of matreya
so matreya would speak through him to
warn the world about what was about to
take place
and it's scary too because some of the
things that he was being told are
correct
but then there was also a lot of things
that were mixed that were wrong so the
devil loves to bring truth and error
because if it's got a little bit of
truth in it people will swallow the
whole thing and then they're poisoned
and die
but listen to what benjamin creme said
he said speaking of matreya he has been
expected for generations by all the
major religions
although the names are different
many believe that they all refer to the
same individual
the world teacher whose personal name is
matreya
and you can look him up online on
youtube and you can find numerous and
i'm not encouraging people because
you're listening to somebody who's being
inspired by the devil
so you know
to do research to understand that's good
but pray before you do the research
because there's sometimes i started to
listen and do an interview with somebody
and i'm like
i can feel
i can feel there's evil spirits i saw an
interview with morgan freeman that he
was doing and it was like i was sitting
there and it was like the lord spoke to
me and said cut it off you're listening
to the devil talk to you right now and
it was it was you could feel something
inside it was almost like inside your
head
trying to to to rearrange the rubik's
cube
it's like i'm there and it's like my
thoughts were like i'm like wait a
minute that's uh get it back on the
bible but you could feel
a spirit trying to change the way that
you were thinking by listening
okay just since you brought that up
while i'm putting together this thing on
the law of attraction man it i can see
the appeal to people i mean
you just say these things and it's going
to change your life positivity you know
be positive and good things that come to
your life there's a lot of like
subtle truths in there and you're like
they just take jesus out yeah
yeah i can see what you're talking about
let's go one more here's another one
from the dalai lama he's probably one of
the world's greatest religious leaders
he said
world peace must develop from inner
peace
peace is not just the absence of
violence
peace is the manifestation there's that
word again of human compassion okay so
far so good
matreya the buddha of loving-kindness
the very name matri means
loving-kindness in today's world we
really need maatri matreya
loving-kindness now we've gone left yeah
so it's like it's love and you're good
with that but then if love steps out of
what god's word says
then
it's a different love it's false this is
what's interesting
daniel chapter
8 verse 24 through 25 and revelation
chapter 13 verse 1 through 2
speaking about this power in the last
days the antichrist power it says
his power shall be mighty
but not by his own power so this being
is going to have
miracle working power but it's not of
himself
he shall destroy wonderfully and shall
prosper and practice
and he shall destroy the mighty and the
holy people
so whoever this antichrist figure is
this this coming cosmic christ it says
he'll destroy the mighty and the holy
people
and through his policy he shall cause
craft that means treachery and deceit to
prosper in his hand
so when you see people that are
proclaiming god can give us victory over
sin
and they're being persecuted and they're
saying god wants us to be holy and
they're being persecuted
this power that claims to be christian
is persecuting those that are
proclaiming god can give us victory yeah
there'll probably be a lot of christians
who won't be persecuted because they
conform to this well yeah that's right i
agree with that we can just live in sin
god i'm like look if god saved me from
alcohol can he not save me from every
other sin
why why do i want to be broken that's
like saying no i want to go to the
hospital i just want you to give me some
good food but i want you to touch the
cancer you're like yeah but we can cure
the cancer in a week no no i like the
cancer that's what we say about sin
since killing us and we're going as
christians no i don't want to give sin
up no
it wasn't the beatles that said all you
need is love yeah
wow that's right
over and over again over and over again
i'm going to have to write that down to
remember that that's a good point
speaking of this power it says he shall
magnify himself in his heart
and by peace he shall destroy many by
peace
in order to keep the peace he's going to
destroy many of the holy people that's
interesting right now we're seeing that
yeah i mean this right here alone could
be a whole program but all over the
world we're seeing the whole world
coming together saying we need peace we
need everybody needs to come together as
one we need to set aside our differences
um
but there's only one person that can
bring peace and that's christ he is
the prince of peace
is anything wrong to bring together
peace brother there's nothing wrong
there's nothing wrong with everyone
coming together as one
but the only way everyone can be one is
on god's word amen because otherwise if
i set the truth to the side in order to
become one
your unity as one is a lie and god is
love but what kind of peace the the
world wants to bring doesn't it yeah
it's interesting because
in the tower of babel
he said the people have become as one
look at this evil thing they're doing
but then jesus said i pray that the
people become as one as me and you are
one so there's a different kind of
oneness that he wants and you know it's
interesting because what you just said
jesus said father i pray that they all
might be one as we are one
i am in you and you are in me so if god
is in each of us we're one but if the
enemy is in the rest of the world they
become one and that's what's happening
you're seeing two armies are being
formed you've got those that are filled
with the spirit of the living god and
you've got those that are filled with
every unclean and hateful spirit like
revelation 18.
babylon has fallen she's full of demons
it's talking about people it's not
talking about a building or a city
it's people
so how they want to bring the piece
let me show you a couple of things the p
symbol everybody is familiar with i mean
we see that all the time yeah
um
this one they're actually showing i wish
i had a higher resolution it's got all
the different symbols for all these
different world religions and they're
all saying you know let's come together
in peace the other one the world peace
gong this one was startling and you see
all the major world religions and all
the flags they're all saying we want
peace we want to have the union we want
to have world peace this one caught my
attention aikido
training peaceful warriors for all ages
to lead a peaceful world
okay what
so we've got u.n peacekeeping forces
we're going to go in with guns and we're
going to force you to have peace by
peace he will destroy many
this other one is actually and the only
reason i'm bringing up the martial arts
is because i was in that for so long and
i was like this has nothing to do with
peace what are these people doing
international uchirou world peace
seminar 2013. look at the guys faces
yeah really peaceful yeah i mean those
are the kind of guys i want taking care
of my grandchild i mean you know but
they're they say they're training for
peace and i've got i've got tons of
other posters of this from the same type
of people and they're all saying
we're training in karate for peace we're
training in this for peace we're doing
this for peace
the peace that they want though is not
the peace with god
you can only have peace with god through
christ jesus in christ jesus is the word
of god you can't live in opposition to
god's word and yet have peace with him
this one i thought was interesting you
see the united nations on the left-hand
side you know their symbol and on the
right you see a united nations
symbol for peace look at that dove
does that look like a peaceful happy
joyful dove
that's an angry that looks like that
would peck your eyeballs out if you
didn't do what it wanted you to do so
where do you find that logo i mean the
this is this organization or something
no that's u.n that's the united nations
for peace
just the united nations in period in
general that's one of their logos with
the white doves yeah
surrounding the denver airport
murals and stuff yeah they're like
stabbing the dove
so i mean when i saw that i was like
wait a minute a dove is supposed to be a
symbol of peace that dove does not look
happy
so and there's a reason why i'm showing
that look at this next one here we have
a religious world leader that was at a
huge gathering at the vatican and out of
nowhere
these doves or white pigeons
decided to come down and greet him and
the whole world said this was a miracle
it was all over the news when this
happened he's got a dove now wait a
minute there's a story in the bible
about a dove coming down that's right on
another person
jesus
what do you think this is
and it's also interesting because this
man his office he claims to be christ on
earth the vicar of christ
in the place of god i've even seen when
he attended the united nations like
they introduced them as the holy father
and everybody stands up and claps i'm
just like
excuse me
i know that was interesting when my wife
went on a mission trip to israel she
said um she had an islamic
man that was driving their their bus
and they were driving and he was being
pretty quiet because all these are like
christians that are on this trip and
then all of a sudden there was a huge
billboard on the side of the road had a
picture of the pope on it and he said
look look the holy father
and my wife is like
he's not my father
and
when she said that she said there was
anger in his eyes she said all the
muslims there they all look to the pope
and say he's number one wow i know and
my wife came home and she was like i
used to think walter vice was you know a
little bit of a nut she said i went
there and i saw it she said it's exactly
the way he described it he said you'll
see a mosque on one side of the street
and there'll be a catholic cathedral on
the other side and he said they're
almost identical
this life made connection we showed that
in a video of his topic is islamic
what's like steve harvey
did you see that video there's a video
steve harvey right now talking about how
his son is a muslim or something and
anyway steve harvey is a self-professed
christian but on this video he's coming
out wearing all the muslim garb
and for some reason they they talk about
this mosque or it's a a catholic church
no it's a mosque
that says
our mother mary or something yeah and
yeah it was it was really weird and
they've got they've got uh the muslims
in in israel or not in israel but in
that area the arab world they've got a
mosque there and they have a saint that
they call um john the baptist
and they actually in the mosques they
have like a little room where you can go
in and that's they say that's where
you're supposed to worship and pray to
john the baptist wow and i'm like that's
weird
yeah but they're really strict on only
one god and all this you know yeah
this one was another one that was
interesting this is a buddhist
organization and
this is a quote from what the
bhagavad-gita this is a hindu religious
book it says
to re-establish dharma
i come again and again
according to the hindus and the
buddhists like with the matreya
the matreya will manifest every thousand
years every two thousand years as a new
figure last time he was here they say
was when jesus christ was here they say
that was actually matreya that was
manifesting in christ
so
they say this time matrey is coming as
himself not manifesting like he did in
buddha or in jesus
which is a lie
and this will be the last time that's
what they say
here's another lady from matreya
teachings.org she says matreya is an
ascended master a highly evolved
spiritual being remember on the one we
did yesterday where we talked about its
evolution
evolution to godhood
she says matreya is a highly evolved
spiritual being who is in charge of the
office of christ
they say the office of christ consists
of many thousands of ascended masters
ascended masters means you've been in
some occult practice like keith and i
were in in martial arts or in key gong
or in yoga and you reach enlightenment
you actually reach nirvana or
enlightenment and then you become an
ascended master and when you die you
don't die you become one with the
universal energy which is what obi-wan
and yoda and all them said you become
one with the force
those who all those movies are doing is
they're teaching us this doctrine
so she says the office of christ
consists of many thousands
of ascended masters including jesus
muhammad guatemala the buddha and mother
mary she's saying all of them are christ
figures
then she says matreya was in charge of
the office of christ
when the christ energy was channeled
through jesus some two thousand years
ago
matreya now speaks to the human channels
around the world to convey his message
of the coming of the new age
that manifests through these people's
lives and what they do with christ is
they say well christ was a human being
that was filled with the matreya energy
so they can then profess that they
believe in jesus but you don't know what
they mean when they say that
so question how this person
mark
uh how she knows this information i mean
it's just they channel it through
spirits who give all the information
just the spirit yes
you know you can go into a meditation or
you go into a trance or maybe you have a
vision and you wake up and you do
automatic hands i mean there's a lot of
information so i was like okay how this
person get information you know maybe
books or um somebody else you remember
alice bailey and madame blavowski they
did the same thing alice bailey wrote
tons of books and she would sit down and
a spirit would move her hand she would
watch her hand as it was writing and it
would dictate the words to it and as the
new age or is a different uh this person
no it's new age new age but old new age
like back in the 1800s early 1900s and
we believe this to be true we wrestle
not against flesh and blood i'm sure
satan visited all those people he
visited jesus but they have his story
wrong because jesus declined that
partnership amen amen
here's another lady she is the one that
really promoted a course in miracles her
name is miriam williamson now listen
we're seeing something common about what
these different people are saying about
christ
she says the name of jesus christ as
such as such
is but a symbol it is a symbol that is
safely used as a replacement for the
many names of all the gods to which you
pray
so see you see what the devil's doing
now you know you worship this god you
worship that god you worship that god
yeah but they're all the same we're just
calling them by different names she goes
on and says and this is actually a quote
from her book a course in miracles for
christ takes many forms with different
names until their oneness can be
recognized jesus and other enlightened
masters are our evolutionary elder
brothers that's terrifying
that's terrifying but this is how the
devil's preparing for the last great
deception he's getting the whole world
the course in miracles oprah winfrey
promoted this for over a year on our
show to millions
millions of people partook of this and
they think it was true
it's very interesting i mean they put
the name you know right there a director
encounter with jesus christ
in the evolution and enlightenment of
the universe they put that word jesus
christ you know they put that name you
know i'm saying so everybody's like oh
you know what i mean it's gonna be a
good christian book or maybe something
more information uh you know instead of
the bible maybe it's another mystical
thing that we didn't know as a christian
let's read that book you know and i mean
yeah
even if you read the whole thing a
direct encounter with jesus christ
that's christian
in an evolution of in enlightenment i
mean our walk is a growth an evolution
if you will so i mean yeah that's very
deceiving to a christian it is that's
when you open the cover
yeah i mean you at the end of the day
you have to choose one or the other
the bible plainly says
who is a liar but he who denies that
jesus is the christ
amen and after that it says he is
antichrist who denies the father
and the son amen
so you don't you know the world is
offering one version one option the
bible has the other you have to make a
choice which one is true
if this is true that cannot be true amen
and that that's very simple it's the
bottom line and you know it's funny too
because like people will say
certain religions well they believe in
jesus but they don't believe he was the
son of almighty god
what keith just said you're antichrist
whoever denies the father and the son is
antichrist
it also says whoever denies that christ
came in the flesh it doesn't mean he
came in just flesh it means our flesh
he took our nature
and he overcame it benjamin cram now
listen to this this was pretty startling
benjamin creme said in the esoteric
tradition the christ is not the name of
an individual but of an office in the
hierarchy a position
he says that the present holder of that
office is lord matria and he has held it
for 2600 years
and manifested there's that word again
in palestine through his disciple jesus
all of a sudden he's calling jesus the
disciple of this being matreya
he says by the occult method of
overshadowing
isn't that an interesting term there's
somewhere in the bible where it talks
about the spirit of god overshadowed
when jesus was there and he was healing
and it says the spirit of the lord
and it uses a word that implies that i
don't remember the situation but jesus
was healing people and it said the
spirit of the lord was there in power
while he was doing this in order that it
could be done
it says this is the most frequent form
used for the manifestation of what's
that word candy
avatars avatars
when's that new movie come out have they
released the second one yet or is he
still working with james cameron that
film came out almost all almost 10 years
ago it was 2000 what 10
2011. it looks like december 16 of next
year okay
well this is this is why we want to look
at that because people go oh it's a cool
movie avatar they do not come up with
names out of a hat yeah it's not like
you just go i need some kind of weird
name you look at the movie avatar
and it was
a mixture or a movie about the union of
a man with an alien creature
the man's mind in the alien creature's
body
let me show you
what the word avatar means in the hindu
the word avatar means
those that fell or descended from the
heavens i was just thinking it looks
like a hindu god
blue yes from yes alien from heaven
right yeah
and what what's amazing is is
it was a human mind
in an alien body human possessing again
now you've got the truth is
demons manifesting in human flesh
here's another definition it says also
defined as the descent the appearing the
manifestation or incarnation of a hindu
god such as visnu krishna or siva to the
earth this is what they said about
christ
in addition hinduism confers the title
of avatar to extraordinary individuals
who have experienced
self-realization
that means
i realize that i'm god
and union with the universal energy
before you're going to jump on that i
wouldn't just want to make a
a comment uh do you know that the movie
avatar it was
the high movie of uh people
after they watched a movie i mean we're
talking about like three hours
of that movie
and
people are finished watching the movie
and they had these suicidal suicidal
thoughts check out this comment left on
a fan website here it is when i woke up
this morning after watching avatar for
the first time yesterday the world
seemed great it was like my whole life
everything i've done and worked for
lost its meaning
lost its meaning after watching this
movie that's what's going on here call
in want to hear from you all right joe
did these people who are posting i mean
are they adding details of their life uh
so you kind of know well hey life isn't
that great so yes that would make the
movie in this world that much more
appealing i think the great thing is on
these online forums now they're finding
a community of people who feel the same
way and through finding that community
they're starting to feel better about
themselves and about their life do you
know what you know what's interesting
because i've read the article
and that's what cnn said they said this
is what we believe is causing the
suicidal thoughts let me tell you what i
believe cause
avatar means the manifestation of those
that fell from heaven
demons fell from heaven fallen angels
fell from heaven
people go and watch for three hours
evil spirits manifesting in actors and
those spirits are then influencing the
thoughts of suicide and depression
i was setting a wicked thing before my
eyes why because you're inviting in
demons you're opening the door yeah
that's scary we talked about this man on
one of our previous shows pierre tilhard
d chardin he said i believe that the
messiah whom we await whom we all
without any doubt await is the universal
christ that is to say the christ of
evolution this is a jesuit priest
this man spoke to
he influenced a lot of the people of the
u.n
and he was telling them
just like benjamin krem the matreya is
coming
the u.n is preparing for this event and
i don't want to get into too much
weirdness but
we've also seen
just since 2019
the whole world has turned upside down
about the fear about aliens and all that
our current president at that time trump
said we're initiating a new
armed force
the space force the sixth the branch
indefinitely the six
six six six we had five branches of the
armed forces in 2019 he said now we're
going to have the six it's called space
force and i thought okay i mean i'm not
belittling trump okay he was fun to
watch but but i'm like
he was he was character he was not what
yeah you he you wouldn't look at him and
go hey he's a presidential candidate you
know the agenda would have happened no
matter who was in yeah who the face of
the president was
but he's just doing orders man for me
watching him i was like okay i mean you
know because he's just he's a character
but then i saw vice president
uh pence get up there and pence is like
presidential i mean he looks like he
plays the part
he looks serious he's not joking i'm not
a clown i'm not goofing off i'm not you
know he was like this is what we're
gonna do and they announced this at
military bases
well then i was like okay i wonder who
else is doing this i got online there
are numerous other nations in the world
france i think japan and there was a
couple other ones i found back in 2019
they all initiated the same type of
space
warfare program the same year
in the last six months we have seen
unbelievable amounts of stuff come out
on the news
the pentagon has just been commanded
before president trump you know
left office that they had to release all
the documents
something is about to happen they are
preparing for something to happen so
these is a jesuit guy right yes that he
teach and he said i believe that
the messiah
is a universal christ this universe of
christ and is the cr the christ of
evolution it means we all
evolved until we reach christ
so my question is
the pope
right now
save that save that save that we're
almost there save that
have you been reading my notes no man
this is dr m scott peck he's a
psychiatrist and harvard graduate listen
to what he said and he he's written a
number of books he wrote a book called
the road less traveled which praise god
it needs to be less traveled
he says we are growing toward godhood
god is the goal of evolution it is god
who is the source of the evolutionary
force and god who is the destination
this is what's being taught in our world
and in a lot of our seminaries this is
swami
viva kananda he's a hindu was a hindu
guru he said
each soul is potentially divine the goal
is to manifest this divinity within by
controlling nature
external nature and internal nature and
then he says you can achieve this
divinity
either by work or worship or psychic
control or philosophy by one or more or
all of these and be free this is the
whole of religion
we don't see that in lots of video games
especially uh dr
strange i don't think
yeah the bible and this is this is the
counterfeit that they're counterfeiting
god's word says whereby are given unto
us exceeding great and precious promises
that by these we might be made partakers
of the divine nature
by god's promises we're made partakers
not just of the divine character but of
his nature
god's nature is this deity does not sin
deity does not die
wages of sin is death if you don't sin
you don't die
if sin doesn't have dominion over you
death has no dominion over you
that's what the 144 000 the bible says
they're going to come to the place in
their relationship with god where they
believe his promises so much
that they they can't die
wow
that's what god wants
that's what god wants to restore to us
we're going to close that it says then
if any man shall say unto you lo here is
christ or there
believe it not for there shall arise
false christs and false prophets and
they shall show great signs and wonders
in so much that if it were possible they
shall deceive even the very elect
behold i have told you beforehand so
christ has warned us beforehand that
this day was going to come and i think
we're seeing it now like it's never been
seen before a quick overview matreya
buddha
the hindu krishna they're all
proclaiming that they're expecting
krishna to manifest again
physically
the new age cosmic christ there's so
many books on that we don't even have
time to begin to go through them but
they're saying that the cosmic christ is
about to appear
uh the islamic imam mahadi
islam is saying the mahadi is about to
appear
orthodox jewish messiah orthodox
orthodox judaism is proclaiming that the
messiah is about to appear they don't
realize he came once he's coming the
second time
and then you have christians that are
saying
christ is about to return to set up a
kingdom here on earth wow
so it's like the world is being primed
for what we're about to see
every every new age pagan and messianic
belief as well as that of all eastern
mysticism as that man is evolving to
godhood they teach that within each
human being is a god spark that's what
they call it which only needs to be
awakened through occult mystical
practices
once this has been achieved man has said
to have recognized his own divinity
but this isn't verity the same lies
spoken by satan through the serpent to
our parents in the garden of eden you
shall be as gods this is a another hindu
guru swami muktananda listen to what he
said he said it is only when kundalini
and kundalini is the serpent power in
yoga that the whole purpose of yoga is
to awaken awaken that syrup the serpent
that's inside of you and get it to go up
your spine from where it's at the
tailbone
to hear the crown
why would i want a snake to go from down
there to up here i think you need to
repeat what the purpose of yoga is just
one more time
the entire according to them the entire
purpose of yoga is to awaken the
kundalini serpent right not for exercise
not for stretching right
yeah and we've got videos we've done on
yoga that goes through that holy yoga
yeah it says that only when the
kundalini
is awakened that we become aware of our
true
nature
of our greatness of the fact that not
only do we belong to god but that we are
god that's what they say the hindus when
one acquires the strength of kundalini
one expands infinitely
and then one assimilates the whole
universe
one is able to see the whole universe
within oneself
one no longer remains a bound limited
creature
because one achieves total union with
what they call god
that's terrifying
because they're being joined in union
with pagan gods with evil spirits moriah
uesheba he was the founder of aikido he
said the the art of peace i practice has
room for each of the world's eight
million gods and i cooperate with them
all i've had many people that have
written to me and they go eric what
about you sheba i mean he talked about
god i had a number of his books and he
would say that in there the god i
worship and he sounded really good
and then you find a quote like this and
you're like
did you know that the god he worshipped
includes eight million gods
jesus said there's one god and i'm one
with him he said the god of peace is
very great and enjoins or includes all
that is divine and enlightened in every
land the divine is not something high
above us it is in heaven it is in earth
it is inside us that's pantheism
this is a quote from great controversy
um 1888 version
page 561
this one is powerful listen to what
we're told satan has long been preparing
for his final effort to deceive the
world
the foundation of his work was laid by
the assurance given to eve and eden you
shall not surely die for in the day ye
eat thereof your eyes shall be opened
and you shall be as gods god said the
wages of sin is death satan said you
won't die
if you sin you'll know good and evil
then you'll be like god little by little
satan has prepared the way for his
masterpiece of deception in the
development of spiritualism he has not
yet reached the full accomplishment of
his designs but it will be reached in
the last remnant of time so what he
began in eden
telling man that you can become a god
has something to do with the very last
deception
man being proclaimed as god
and we saw that when we opened up with
second thessalonians
he will sit in the temple of god
claiming to be
god
and the bible calls him the man of sin
a lot of people like you were talking
about mikey when they when they hear the
word antichrist they think it's this
person that hates christianity he hates
the bible
yeah against but the word antichrist in
the scripture actually means the one who
stands in place of christ or a
counterfeit or substitute or a vicar of
christ so the word has a completely
different meaning than what most
christians realize how many people have
ever heard of john bunyan
yeah not paul bunyan but john lennon um
pilgrim's progress right a powerful book
and there's a good version of that
called uh the amplified yeah it's by a
man named jim pappas if you ever get a
chance to read it you can't put it down
um
listen to what bunyan said and this was
written back almost 500 years ago he
said antichrist is the adversary of
christ an adversary really a friend
pretendedly
so then antichrist is one that is
against christ
one that is for christ and one that is
contrary to him
this is that mystery of iniquity
he is against christ indeed
for christ in word and yet contrary to
him in practice
i thought this 500 years ago
wow
when protestantism shall stretch your
hand across the gulf and grasp the hand
of the roman power and we're seeing that
now protestants evangelicals are
clasping hands with the roman power when
she shall reach over the abyss and clasp
hands with spiritualism that's why we're
seeing all the spiritualism being
introduced through movies and music and
video games and books
is getting christians
that claim they love jesus to take hold
of another hand when under the influence
of this threefold union apostate
protestantism roman catholicism and
spiritualism our country shall make
provision for the spread of papal
falsehoods and delusions
then we may know that the time has come
for the marvelous working of satan
that's that last great deception
and that the end is near this is from a
periodical in 1896. listen to what we're
told called review in herald april 14.
as the second appearing of our lord
jesus christ draws near satanic agencies
are moved from beneath satan will not
only appear as a human being but he will
personate christ
this is just food for thought i could be
wrong okay food for thought
there's two ways that i read that
satan will not only appear as a human
being but he will personate christ it's
like he's not going to do this but he is
going to do this
or
satan will not only appear as a human
being but he's also going to impersonate
christ
when christ came the first time
god was manifest in the flesh emmanuel
and there's places in the bible in the
gospels where it says there were a few
times in christ's ministry where his
divinity flashed through
humanity
it's almost like this earthen vessel
could not contain the glory that was in
him and christ was so full of the power
of his father and the holy spirit that
it flashed through humanity
if christ came in the flesh
and his glory flashed through humanity
what if satan comes first as a man
and that glory of his angelic majesty
flashes through humanity do you know
what the world would say
man has become a god right
the whole world if that was to happen
where you had a man
the world looks up to and then he starts
doing miracles and glory
is manifest the whole world would say
he's done exactly what we all want to
become gods exactly what satan declared
what happened in genesis the serpent
it was all the way to the top
yes
listen to this it says and the world who
has rejected the truth of god's word
will receive him as lord of lords and
king of kings satan will exercise his
power and he will work upon the human
imagination he will corrupt both the
minds and bodies of men and will work
through the children of disobedience
fascinating and charming as does the
serpent
we opened with this let no man deceive
you by any means for that day if christ
returns shall not come except there come
a falling away first and that man of sin
be
unveiled unmasked
if satan actually is hiding inside of a
man remember son of perdition
judas
satan entered into him into a man to do
his work
if that son of perdition is
unmasked he's going to be revealed for
who he really is this was interesting
time magazine
hope for a new world
i mean
wow you could just put it out there
there's lots of different magazines that
have
you know hosted or portrayed
pope francis i'm just going to show you
a couple of quotes from the protestant
reformers and this is i'm doing this
also for our brothers and sisters that
may be in different churches they don't
know what their founders said let me
just go through a couple of these john
wycliffe he lived from 1324 to 1384.
he was the mooring star of the
protestant reformation listen to what he
said
it is supposed and with much probability
that the roman pontiff is the great
antichrist
that was i mean 1700 years ago almost
yes i'm sorry 700 thank you keith
martin luther 14
1483-1546 he was a lutheran
he said i am practically cornered and
can hardly doubt anymore that the pope
is really the antichrist because
everything so exactly corresponds to the
way of his life actions words and his
commandments
already he said i feel greater liberty
in my heart for at last i know the pope
is antichrist and that his throne is
that of satan himself strong words that
is strong words
but you know what
just recently within the past two years
the roman catholic church has said we
forgive
martin luther for what he did and we're
welcoming him back home
and the lutheran church has jumped right
on board william tyndall lived from 1493
to 1536.
listen to what he said
the jews look for christ and he has come
1500 years ago and they are not aware
likewise we also have looked for
antichrist
and he has reigned as long and we are
not aware
this was
in the 1500s
he's saying
antichrist has been reigning and we've
been looking in the wrong place
john calvin 1509 to 1564. he was a
presbyterian he said some persons think
us too severe and centurious when we
call the roman pontiff antichrist
but those who are of this opinion do not
consider that they bring the same charge
of presumption against paul himself
after whom we speak and whose language
we adopt
i shall briefly show that paul's words
in 2nd thessalonians chapter 2 are not
capable of any other interpretation than
that which applies them to the papacy
that's powerful
the westminster confession of faith in
1647 there's a lot of evangelicals that
hold to this doctrine in that confession
of faith they said there is no other
head of the church but the lord jesus
christ nor can the pope of rome in any
sense be head thereof but is that
antichrist that man of sin and the son
of perdition that exalted themself in
the church against christ and all that
is called god i wish our brothers and
sisters knew this
charles spurgeon baptist
many many evangelical and protestant
churches
literally look up to him listen to what
he said he lived from 1834 to 1892.
he said it is the bound duty of every
christian to pray against antichrist
and as to what antichrist is
no sane man ought to raise a question
if it be not the potpourri in the cho
church of rome
there is nothing in the world that can
be called by that name you can't be any
clearer yeah than that some of you may
remember this you remember when pope
francis first was elected to office
there was an event and i've had to do a
lot of research to go back to find it
and it's hidden it's been hidden well
but when the event happened it was all
over the news
when he went when he was elected they
came and told him that he had been
elected and he asked if he could step
inside of a room in the vatican alone
and he closed the door and he went into
the room don't know how long he stayed
in there don't have any details as to
that maybe somebody knows but he went
into that room for a little while
when he came out there were testimonies
from the bishops in the news the bishops
that knew him before he was elected to
pope different person they said it's not
the same person that walked into the
room
he looks the same we know it's the same
man but he's com his character is
completely different they said he was
always somber very solemn he was a
jesuit i mean you don't you don't be a
jesuit you're not giggly and goofy
[Music]
when he came out of the room they said
he was charismatic not like speaking in
tongues but he was
loving hugging babies and kissing
muslims and and washing muslims feed and
very
playing pop christian pop music right i
mean at the vatican that's never
happened we've never seen a pope do that
before
his own sister
actually said the same thing
she said
i don't i know this is my brother but i
don't recognize the man she said this is
not the man that i've always known
something changed when he went in there
so i started looking because i
remembered when this happened i guess it
was back in like 2013 do you remember
the date that he was elected i think it
was 2013.
um
but when he was elected
it was everywhere and i went online to
find it you couldn't find anything
except articles that were saying it was
all a fraud and i'm like well that's
convenient we rewrite history like 1984
or george orwell make it fit what we
want
but i found the source of where the
story came from it was an interview with
an italian man named scalfari
uh it was september 24 2013. scalfari
was a roman catholic and he had gotten
very disillusioned with the catholic
church and so he became a pronounced
open atheist i mean and he also wrote uh
a journal he had a
like a periodical a magazine like every
month or every couple of weeks this
magazine came out and he opened this
magazine up and he would condemn the
church the roman catholic church in
italy
for all the abuses and the things he
thought was wrong about it
well
one day
pope francis picked up the phone and
called him personally on the phone and
said i'd like to meet with you
not an interview
this is just a meeting i would like to
meet with you
so the man was sort of taken aback
and pope francis is trying to say i can
win by peace
this man professes to hate me to hate
the church now let me show you what the
church is going to do we're going to
love him anyway so the pope met with him
for a couple of hours you know he had
his guards that were around but not
sitting right there with him and these
two older men i don't remember how old
scalfaria is but he's an older man
i think older than the pope they had
this discussion
and the pope described
that event of when he went into that
room and he said a supernatural thing
happened to him
he said everything changed inside of him
he said and i knew i had complete peace
that i was supposed to take this
position
and he described this to scalfari
scalfari has been interviewing people
for years
every time he does an interview he never
has a recorder he never uses a tape
recorder never digitally records he
doesn't even take notes he's just got a
memory wow and they know that
they know that because of every other
interview he's done
well now the vatican has come out and
said look scalpari lied he's not telling
the truth you know it wasn't even an
interview he didn't have any recording
of it he has no proof and scalfari when
he heard this he actually released
another statement in his paper and he
said
if what the pope said is false all the
pope has to do is come out publicly and
denounce what i said
the pope has never done that
ever
and as an atheist i mean what kind of
agenda does this guy really have yeah
that sounds more like a supernatural
thing that atheists would just disregard
as whatever yeah and for me you know
like the vatican they released i've got
a picture here of the vatican news where
they talked about how it was it was
really misinterpreted you know the pope
really didn't say those things there's
not really the room where he said the
room was and i was like so who do you
believe
well when you realize that the word
vatican actually means the divining
serpent
and serpents have four tongues i mean
you can't believe what's coming out of
their mouth because they're speaking out
of both sides
i'm like you know you got to make your
own decision about that
to go on just a little bit great
controversy page 6 24. listen to this
the crowning act in the great drama of
deception
satan himself will personate christ the
church has long professed to look to the
savior's advent as the consummation of
her hopes now the great deceiver will
make it appear that christ has come
this is the strong almost over mastering
delusion this is what christ said don't
even go look
i mean don't even go look like the
samaritans who were deceived by simon
magus in acts chapter 8 the multitudes
from the least to the greatest will give
heed to these sorceries saying this is
the great power of god but this is a
great promise the people of god will not
be misled amen the teachings of this
false christ are not in accordance with
god's word with the scriptures his
blessing is pronounced upon the
worshipers of the beast in his image the
very class upon whom the bible declares
that god's unmingled wrath shall be
poured out so it's by god's word that
we'll be able to detect the deception
also i want to share with you
very interesting you know you were
talking about the in the latin you know
vatican is serpent the divining serpent
yeah that's right and in the beginning
also we were talking you were mentioned
i know quetzalcoatl you know yeah the
prophecy you know stuff but do you know
what the means gets caught
the and i'm saying quetzalcoatl but
that's how i pronounce but i'm not
pronouncing it correct you're saying it
correctly yeah do you know what that
means i don't know what it means what
does it mean well it's the is the
language of the aztecs with uh now what
and it means it's a divine
why this is the divine the word the word
worship right
that means serpent with feathers
really yeah it's
do you know do you know what's so weird
about that
the ancient hebrew
the ancient hebrew writings
describe
that the serpent
before lucifer before not lucifer satan
before satan had spoken through it you
know used it as a medium
they described the serpent as having
wings
which would be feathers yeah in all the
ancient chinese writings
you see the description of the dragon as
if it were a serpent with wings and and
legs and you go to these pyramids and
you see
that like the dragon or like a serpent
with feathers yes i've seen i've seen
photographs
yes so i just wanted to share that with
you i'm glad you shared that because
that ties everything in together and
that that's telling us that all of these
different gods no matter what they're
called they're all going to be
manifestations of satan yeah only those
who have been diligent students of the
scriptures and who have received the
love of the truth
not just that we love the truth the word
of god but we've received
its love his love for us
amen the love of the truth
shall be shielded from the powerful
delusion that takes the world captive by
the bible testimony these will detect
the deceiver in his disguise to all the
testing time will come and then shall
that wicked be revealed we're told in 2
thessalonians whom the lord shall
consume with the spirit of his mouth and
shall destroy with the brightness of his
coming
even him speaking of christ whose coming
is after the working of satan with all
power signs and lying wonders with all
deceivableness of unrighteousness in
them that perish because they received
not the love of the truth that they
might be saved that's what it all comes
down to jesus told us we shall know the
truth and the truth shall make us free
you know what god's word says in john 17
17 jesus said sanctify them through thy
truth thy word is truth
what's the first statement in the bible
that god said
let there be love let there be what
light
let there be do you know what the
promise he's made to us
be therefore holy because i am holy
that's the word of truth do you know
what the bible says in first john 3
verse 1 and 2 beloved now we are sons
and daughters of god and it does not
appear what we shall be but we know when
he appears we're going to be just like
him
[Music]
so we've got many people that are going
i want to be a child of god but i don't
know how to get there and god's going
you are stand up and walk like it
we are begotten again by the word of
truth
that's what our safety is in in god's
word alone what a great study man i love
talking about last day's events i love
that we have the true enlightenment amen
of god thank you so much for you know
showing us line upon line and
bringing the pieces together man this is
really becoming really clear if you guys
want to see more about this subject you
can actually watch a documentary from a
friend of ours called school for
prophets but the video is called from
babylon to america it has over 6 million
views collectively and rightfully so
it's a very good documentary so check
that out if some of this was like
intriguing to you but maybe you want to
study more on it that video has a lot in
there if you want to see more of eric
wilson's stuff you can go to where um
well you just have to go to youtube and
type in ericwilson7
and that that takes you to our our
ministry page all right we'll put that
link in the description thank you guys
so much for being with us don't forget
to like share and subscribe
and we'll see you guys next time god
bless
[Music]
you